Dans certains cas, c'est parce qu'ils sont mauvais,
ou immoraux,
mais souvent, ils nous ont menés vers les mauvais objectifs.
Et cela est inacceptable.
Ceci doit s'arrêter.
Comment va-t-on corriger ces erreurs ?
Comment va-t-on choisir la bonne voie ?
Ça ne va pas être facile.
J'ai longtemps travaillé avec des équipes de talent
et elles ont choisi les bons objectifs et les mauvais objectifs.
Beaucoup ont réussi, d'autres ont échoué.
Et aujourd'hui, je vais partager avec vous
ce qui fait vraiment la différence -
c'est ce qui est crucial,
comment et pourquoi
elles se fixent des objectifs sérieux et audacieux,
les bons objectifs pour les bonnes raisons.
Retournons en 1975.
Ouais, c'est moi.
J'ai beaucoup à apprendre, je suis ingénieur informatique,
j'ai les cheveux longs,
mais je travaille sous Andy Grove,
qui a été nommé le meilleur manager de son époque et de toutes les autres.
Andy était un superbe leader et aussi un professeur.
Il m'a dit : « John, ce que tu sais n'a presque pas d'importance.
La réalisation, c'est ce qui est le plus important. »
Et donc, Andy inventa un système appelé « Objectifs et résultats clés »
Ça sonne bien, n'est-ce pas ?
Et tout tourne autour de la réalisation parfaite.
Alors, voici une vidéo classique des années 70
du Professeur Andy Grove.
« Les deux phrases clés de la gestion par les systèmes d'objectifs
sont les objectifs et les résultats clés et ils correspondent à leurs deux buts.
L'objectif est la direction.
Les résultats doivent être mesurés,
mais à la fin, on peut regarder et sans argumenter, dire :
« Ai-je fait cela, oui ou non ? » Oui. Non. Simple.
John Doerr : C'est bien Andy !
Oui. Non. Facile.
Les objectifs et résultats clés
ou ORC,
sont un système simple pour se fixer des objectifs
et ils fonctionnent pour des organismes, pour des équipes
et même pour les individus.
Les objectifs sont ce qu'on veut avoir accompli.
Les résultats clés sont comment je vais faire pour y arriver.
Objectifs. Résultats clés.
Quoi et comment.
Mais voici la vérité :
nous sommes beaucoup à mal fixer nos objectifs
et la plupart ne s'en fixent même pas.
Beaucoup d'entreprises atteignent leurs objectifs.
Elles expédient leurs produits, en lancent de nouveaux
et font du profit,
mais elles n'ont pas de but pour motiver leurs équipes.
Alors, comment bien fixer ces objectifs dès le départ ?
Premièrement, vous devez répondre à la question « Pourquoi ? »
Pourquoi ?
Parce que des équipes vraiment transformationnelles
combinent leurs ambitions à leur passion et à leur but,
et elles développent une vision claire du pourquoi.
Voici une petite histoire.
Je travaille avec une formidable entrepreneuse.
Son nom est Jini Kim.
Elle gère une entreprise appelée Nuna.
C'est une société de traitement de données médicales.
Quand Nuna a été créée,
ils traitaient les données médicales d'employés de grandes entreprises.
Deux ans après,
le gouvernement a publié la proposition
de créer la toute première base de données de Medicaid sur le cloud.
Et vous vous rappelez que Medicaid est le programme
qui touche 70 millions d'Américains,
les pauvres, les enfants
et les personnes handicapées.
Seulement 15 personnes travaillaient alors à Nuna
et cette base de données devait être faite en un an,
et ils avaient de nombreux engagements à honorer,
et franchement, ils n'allaient pas gagner beaucoup avec ce projet.
C'était un de ces moments à quitte ou double,
et Jini l'a saisi.
Elle a sauté sur l'occasion. Elle n'a pas hésité.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que pour Jini, c'est personnel.
Kimong, son petit frère, est autiste.
À sept ans,
il a fait sa première crise d'épilepsie
à Disneyland.
Il est tombé sur le sol. Il a arrêté de respirer.
Les parents de Jini sont des immigrants coréens.
Ils sont arrivés dans le pays avec peu de ressources
parlant très peu anglais.
C'est donc Jini qui a dû inscrire sa famille à Medicaid.
Elle avait alors neuf ans.
Ce moment a défini sa mission,
et cette mission a défini son entreprise.
Cette entreprise a remporté le contrat et l'a exécuté.
Jini vous explique pourquoi.
« Ma famille a évité la pauvreté grâce à Medicaid.
Aujourd'hui, c'est ce qui soutient Kimong et des millions de personnes.
Nuna, c'est ma lettre d'amour à Medicaid.
Chaque ligne de données est une vie
qui mérite d'être racontée avec respect. »
Cette histoire nous explique
que le « pourquoi » peut être le tremplin de nos objectifs.
Souvenez-vous, c'est ce qu'on veut avoir accompli.
Les objectifs sont importants,
ils reposent sur l'action,
ils sont inspirants
et ils ont l'effet d'un vaccin contre les idées vagues.
Pour une vedette,
la technique de l'ORC n'est sûrement pas importante
et pourtant, Bono l'a utilisée pendant des années
pour mener une guerre contre la pauvreté et la maladie.
Son organisation ONE se concentre sur deux objectifs
vraiment grandioses et audacieux.
D'abord, réduire la dette
des pays les plus pauvres au monde.
Ensuite, rendre accessible le traitement contre le VIH.
Pourquoi ces objectifs sont-ils bons ?
Revenons à notre liste.
Importants ? Oui. Concrets ? Oui.
Pragmatiques ? Oui.
Inspirants ?
Écoutons ce qu'en dit Bono.
« Vous êtes passionnés ?
À quel point ?
Quelles actions avez-vous accomplies ?
Si le cœur et l'esprit ne battent pas au même rythme,
alors, votre passion n'est rien.
La technique ORC cultive la folie,
la chimie qui s'y trouve.
Ça crée un environnement propice au risque,
à la confiance,
où l'échec n'est pas synonyme de licenciement.
Fort de cette structure et de cet environnement,
et entouré des bonnes personnes,
la magie opère. »
JD : C'est génial.
L'ORC cultive la folie,
et la magie opère.
C'est parfait.
Donc, Jini nous a expliqué pourquoi,
Bono nous a expliqué l'ABC des objectifs.
Maintenant, voyons les façons d'y arriver.
Ces façons sont les résultats clés
pour atteindre les objectifs.
De bons résultats sont précis et contraints.
Ils sont agressifs, mais réalistes.
Ils sont mesurables et vérifiables.
Voilà de bons résultats clés.
En 1999, j'ai introduit les ORC auprès des cofondateurs de Google,
Larry et Sergey.
Les voici, à 24 ans, dans leur garage.
Sergey a dit avec enthousiasme qu'il voulait les adopter.
Enfin, pas tout à fait.
Ce qu'il a vraiment dit, c'est :
« Nous n'avons pas d'autre moyen de gérer cette entreprise, donc, essayons. »
(Rires)
Et j'ai pris ça pour une approbation.
Mais, depuis, tous les trimestres,
tous les Googlers ont écrit leurs objectifs et leurs résultats clés.
Ils les ont classés
et les ont publiés afin que tout le monde les voie.
Ils ne sont pas utilisés pour les bonus ou les promotions.
Ils sont mis de côté.
Ils sont utilisés dans un but plus grand,
celui d'un engagement collectif
à atteindre les objectifs.
En 2008, un Googler, Sundar Pichai, a décidé d'un objectif,
celui de bâtir la nouvelle plateforme client
pour le futur des applications web.
En d'autres termes, développer le meilleur navigateur.
Il a beaucoup réfléchi en choisissant ses résultats clés.
Comment mesurer le meilleur navigateur ?
Le nombre de clics sur les pubs ou l'engagement.
Non. Il s'est dit : le nombre d'utilisateurs
parce que les utilisateurs décideront
si Chrome est un navigateur génial ou pas.
Donc, il avait cet objectif à trois ans : développer le meilleur navigateur.
Puis, chaque année, il gardait les mêmes résultats clés, le nombre d'utilisateurs,
mais en relevant la barre.
La première année, son but était 20 millions d'utilisateurs, il a échoué.
Il en a eu moins de 10.
La deuxième année, il est monté à 50 millions.
Il a eu 37 millions d'utilisateurs.
Un peu mieux.
La troisième année,
il a de nouveau monté la barre à une centaine de millions.
Il a lancé une campagne marketing agressive,
une distribution plus large, une technologie améliorée et badaboum !
Il a atteint les 111 millions d'utilisateurs.
Voilà pourquoi j'aime cette histoire,
pas tant pour la fin heureuse,
mais ça montre quelqu'un qui choisit avec précaution les bons objectifs
et qui s'y tient année après année.
C'est une histoire parfaite pour un geek comme moi.
Je vois désormais les ORC comme des récipients transparents
composés des quoi et des comment de nos ambitions.
Ce qui importe vraiment, c'est le pourquoi que nous mettons dans ces récipients.
C'est pourquoi nous faisons notre travail.
Les ORC ne sont pas une solution miracle.
Ils ne remplaceront pas une culture forte
ou un fort leadership,
mais quand ces fondamentaux existent,
ils peuvent vous transporter au sommet de la montagne.
Je veux que vous réfléchissiez un instant à votre vie.
Avez-vous les bonnes mesures ?
Prenez le temps d'écrire vos valeurs,
vos objectifs et vos résultats clés.
Faites-le aujourd'hui.
Si vous voulez un avis, vous pouvez me les envoyer.
Je suis john@whatmatters.com
Si nous pensons aux objectifs qui changent le monde,
à un Intel, un Nuna, Bono,
Google,
ils sont fantastiques :
l'informatique ubiquitaire,
les soins abordables, de la haute qualité pour tous,
la fin de la pauvreté mondiale,
l'accès à toute l'information au niveau mondial.
Voici ce que nous avons :
chacun de ces objectifs est soutenu aujourd'hui par les ORC.
Désormais, on m'appelle le chantre des ORC
diffusant la bonne parole d'Andy Grove,
mais je veux que vous me rejoigniez dans ce mouvement.
Battons-nous pour ce qui compte vraiment,
parce que nous pouvons appliquer les ORC au-delà de nos entreprises.
Nous pouvons les appliquer dans nos familles, dans nos écoles,
même dans nos gouvernements.
Nous pouvons tenir ces gouvernements pour responsables.
Nous pouvons transformer ces informations.
Nous pouvons revenir sur le droit chemin
si nous pouvons mesurer et mesurons ce qui compte vraiment.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)